sure all right tom brady will be wearing
number 12 and white
choosing to wear white because he's four
and one in the white jerseys
during his time uh in the nfl
playing in super bowls against the
kansas city chiefs
let's get into some of the news that's
popped up this week and let's start with
um bruce arians and tom brady both
talking this week about what ended up
being the most impactful move of the
2020 offseason getting tom brady
from new england to tampa bay here they
are
you you can't hit a home run if you're
going to swing for one you can
you can't do anything special in life
sitting on a fence
and you know the question back
then was if there was a quarterback that
that was a free agent who would you want
and yeah of course it was tom brady but
um
not thinking he'd become a free agent
but once he did it was
uh it was it was a pursuit that we
wanted to make and uh
knew he had some interest so but again
that's how you live life i don't
you sit and live in a closet and try to
be safe or you go have some damn fun
i'd like to think that i wasn't that
much of a chance uh after a lot of years
yeah uh it but but still 43 it is a
little bit of a chance it is a little
bit of a risk but
bruce erin's no risk get no biscuit he
risked it and they got the biscuit to
the super bowl now
you know and that mentality peter i
think will serve them well in the super
bowl because i think any time you're an
underdog in a postseason game
you have to be willing to do that thing
that disrupts
the predetermined thought as to who the
better team is you got to be willing to
throw the ball the end zone
at the end of the first half you got to
be willing to do the onside kick
back when outside kicks were actually
recoverable at the start of the second
half of super bowl 44.
those are the things you need to be
willing to do and i don't know that
bruce aaron's mentality actually
is going to get into a super bowl very
often this is his first one
but i think the mentality is perfect for
a super bowl when you're the coach of
the team that's favored to lose
mike you know one of the things i really
like about the bucks
personnel acquisition and look it's
been all been about brady but let me
make two other interesting points
about where the bucks are right now one
is that
assuming that everyone's healthy in the
secondary and you can't assume that
because of antoine winfield jr obviously
but if everyone is healthy in the
secondary their top six defensive backs
that they will play on the field
together in this super bowl
at times okay the top six defensive
backs
all 24 or younger every
one of them has come in the last three
drafts tremendous credit
to jason light and his staff and let's
talk about the guy
who tom brady has looked for in huge
moments in the last two playoff games
tyler johnson
not mike evans not cameron breit not
gronk
i mean you know tyler johnson you know
who he is
he's a fifth round draft choice from
minnesota
who last year at the bowl game whichever
it's called the poulon weed eater
cigar bowl or whatever it is that they
hold
in tampa at raymond james stadium
minnesota played
and bruce arians went to the game sat in
one box with his family
jason light went to the game set in
another box with his family
and this guy tyler johnson's making
plays all over the place
and aryan said to at one point after he
made a great catch
he knocks on the window and he says to
uh
light he goes we got to get that guy
and come draft day this year they were
pushing push and pushing
because there was such an incredible
crop
of running backs of wide receivers this
year mike
he slipped all the way to the fifth
round they take him
who is tom brady throwing the ball to
when it's most important on that play
inside the two-minute warning against
green bay
where tyler johnson gets his jersey
pulled and gets the interference
imagine being trusted by tom brady
in the most important play of your
season
and you were a fifth round pick in the
draft that
is what i applaud the bucks for you know
it's a no risk it no biscuit thing
if you love a guy in the draft take him
and then you know what
play him yeah and he made a key third
down catch against the saints on a third
and 11 play the twisted urging diving
catch
how he caught that baby i'll never know
unbelievable and made a
a a key third down catch earlier in the
game against the packers before that
interference penalty let me just say
this
i i have been known to enjoy a fine
cigar i like a monte cristo a partagas
cohiba i would never smoke
the pulling weed eater cigar i don't
want to pull in weed eater cigar
they can sponsor all the bowl games they
want forget it
it ain't working i ain't buying a pool
and a wheatie or cigar
um but but you know that that and and we
talk about executive of the year and pft
for what it matters and it doesn't at
all we made brandon being the bills gmr
executive of the year but i'll tell you
what you can make the argument that
jason light
deserves that consideration not that he
had to go out and scout
and craft and recruit tom brady i think
tom even though
you get the idea or at least they try to
make the case that
he had to sell them come on it's he's
tom brady yeah but to have
to have the pieces there that makes the
team attractive to tom brady is on light
if you don't have the pieces that
they've accumulated over the past six or
seven years
tom brady's going somewhere else he's
not going to tampa bay
yeah totally agree mike and i think the
other thing about
the whole brady situation in tampa
he had done his research he knew as
jason light told me on the
on this podcast this week tom brady
said to him in the middle of their
conversation
uh listen jason there are and i i don't
know
the number but there's 24 952
hours between now and our opening game
of the season
we have to make those count every minute
counts
and so you know when when brady is
talking like that to you
brady wants to come and that to me
says so much about the team that jason
liked
and to some degree bruce arians built
with a really good personnel staff
and it was obvious from the get-go that
they were going to pursue and bruce
aarons was talking openly about it at
the scouting combine
tampering rules be damned and there was
never any consequence for it so what the
hell
tamper away if they're not going to do
anything to you and it worked out
extremely well and the buccaneers
desperately want brady to be back
next year and i'll tell you what peter i
i'm not ready
to to assume that brady stops
in 2022 the year he turns 45.
the way he looks right now there's no
slippage and maybe maybe he's just going
to fall off a cliff
at some point but if he's still playing
like he is now
in 2022 i think that
2023 and 2024 become in play and
hell he may make a run at playing until
he's 50.
you know mike here's a guy who you know
we probably have talked about this once
or twice over the years but
you know one of my vivid memories is
once uh after the super bowl against
atlanta of going to interview him
it was quite a quite a day i went up to
montana and talked to him uh where he
was starting his
offseason vacation seven days earlier he
had
just beaten atlanta and made that huge
comeback and in the course of the
conversation
i said to him don't you ever feel like
just going out and
having like nine beers with your buddies
and he said you know i've done that
before
and i can do it again one day too but
right now this is a lot more fun
than that and you know i i don't want to
do anything
to prevent me from being able to do this
and so i think that has been his ethos
over the years and for anybody who has
kind of made fun of him for
his diet and the electrolytes and and
all this
i just say hey you know what to each his
own
he's not hurting anybody you know let
the guy do what he wants if this is what
he believes it's great
because tom brady you know he said to me
when he was 26 years old
he woke up every day and
you know he had to almost unfold himself
to get him out of bed he was always in
pain
and he said man i love football and i'm
going to keep playing but
i don't know how how long i can deal
with this kind of pain
and then he has gotten into the whole
pliability thing and all that
but i think he is a guy who has figured
out
what you know the number one thing is to
him
in life whatever it is he's figured out
what the most important thing is
and he does it so you know to me all the
power to him
i think the longer he goes the harder it
will be
to stop so you keep going as long as you
can
and you say he's not hurting anyone he's
not but he could get himself hurt that's
the key and that's why we
see in these moments when darnell savage
for example
breaks free on a safety blitz and tom
brady
doesn't want to take that clean hit that
could injure his 43 year old body
so he fires the ball up for grabs and
jair alexander catches it
that's part of what you have to accept
if tom brady is going to be your
quarterback now we've seen it the past
few years
that bail out throw the ball i'm not
going to take that square hit from frank
clark for example or
some other defensive lineman i'm not
going to do it i'll just throw the ball
and if someone intercepts it
hey so be it it's kind of like a short
punt
but also mike you remember peyton
manning late in his career
he he would do what i would call the
fetal sack
you know when he felt the pressure
coming in on him
he just lo he'd just go down and just
take a nap
and i think brady brady does that too
he doesn't do it probably as often as
manning used to do it but he does it too
and he knows that if he's going to make
that
throw the one that jair alexander the
the semi-hail mary
downfield if he's going to make that
throw
he's got to make it so that his guy gets
it or nobody gets it
or it's out of bounds you know and
obviously he short-armed that one
but but i agree with you those are the
things that
you're going to have to live with a few
of them and honestly
if he delivers like he did throwing the
ball 48 yards in the air
uh with seconds left in the first half
and scottie miller
gets by kevin king i i think those i
think that's a pretty nice trade-off
and we go from one quarterback who has
very limited mobility especially at his
age
to a 25 year old who is the slipperiest
not the fastest
not the most agile not the most
explosive
but he's the guy you can't get your
hands on
the 49ers tried to do it last year in
the super bowl many thought they would
succeed
they didn't robert salah who was the
defensive coordinator of the 49ers last
year now the head coach of the jets
was with sims and me earlier this week
and we asked them what advice would you
have
for those tampa bay buccaneers defensive
lineman here's saula from earlier in the
week
anytime you're a pass rusher just
understand that he
he might do his little old man jog in
between plays where he looks like his
feet hurt but
he's got tremendous mobility his arm
strength is ridiculous you have to be
relentless all the way through
headline made me laugh it made someone
else laugh too it made patrick mahomes
laugh he
he retweeted it i saw that on twitter he
responded
with with the the multiple there it is
when you get
six of the laughing crying emojis you
have made someone laugh till they cry
and
uh you know it's it's the truth though
it's kind of like somebody pointed out
it's kind of a baseball thing
like how someone shuffles around in the
infield you know between batters or
something like that like it just
you there's never really an occasion on
the baseball field to run
when you're an infielder except when
you've hit the ball but it's just kind
of that yeah that
i don't know if it's a little
rope-a-dope quality but he does move
like that between plays
but when it's time to elude and evade
defenders
he does it as well as anyone in the nfl
peter
mike you know what i really like about
mahomes at this stage of his career
uh number one uh he realizes that
he can uh he can do things
like on social media and in the outside
world and in interviews
and he can show that side of himself you
know when's the first time you realized
about tom brady and he gives his birth
date
you know the day he was born and and you
know so
mahomes has fun with this stuff he had
fun with rich eisen
on his tv show about his nickname and
and and all that stuff and and not only
that
but i think he knows right now that
you know so many quarterbacks over time
have been so incredibly careful
in press conferences you know and he's
not afraid
to drop a line in a press conference
that might work or it might fall flat
but whatever you know it's not we're not
talking about nuclear physics here we're
just talking about
a game and and the other part of him
right now that i really like
he's playing in all of these big games
all of them he's only 25 years old and
you know whereas josh allen you get the
impression
that josh allen sort of i don't want to
say spit the bit
but that was a huge moment for josh
allen
from wyoming via buffalo you know
to be on that mega stage this early in
his career
and josh allen will be back and he'll be
really really good
but when you get on that stage
it's hard but now mahomes has been on
that stage so often
and played so well that to him it's just
another game
and to brady i'm not saying just another
game that makes it sound flip but
he's going to perform like he would in
an october game against the jets both of
these guys are
that is what a quarterback needs to do
in big games perform like it's any other
game
and look peter i i'm convinced that one
of the reasons why the chiefs struggle
or at least are perceived as struggling
in the regular season
the adrenaline rush isn't the same the
stakes aren't the same
they have grown addicted to that feeling
of playoff football and that's where we
see them rise to a higher level
and it becomes easy to take patrick
mahomes and other chiefs players for
granted during the season
they still played incredibly well they
won 14 out of 15 games that they were
trying to win
but they don't have it as easily you
know they just smothered the bills i
mean we expected i expected it would be
an exciting game and maybe josh allen
is going to show he's on patrick mahomes
level and the moment that the chiefs
took the lead in that game i i
sims and i talked about this earlier in
the week like it's like
it's it's done it's over it's just a
detail as to what the final score is at
this point
mike you know what i was thinking about
this watching that game
well you know how at least i was i was
kind of making a big deal of
this team was not playing well on
offense at the end of the year
at all that game against atlanta was a
nightmare then they sat
and they sat for 20 days and i'm wagging
my finger at andy reid like
hey andy i know more football than you
do
you shouldn't be arresting these guys
and then all of a sudden they come out
and they look like the 27 yankees so i
i just i i really feel like
you know it to me it's it's something
that andy reid
really knows his team he knows his
quarterback
and he did the right thing yeah
absolutely and one of those regular
season games was a
win over the tampa bay buccaneers week
12
the last time the buccaneers lost they
had their bye week 13
they finished the regular season 4-0
they've won three road games in the
postseason so from
seven and five to seven and oh how much
does the game where the chiefs raced out
to a 17 to nothing lead over the
buccaneers
how much does that matter when they get
together again
in the super bowl i think it really
helps to have a
veteran uh you know flatline
coach excuse me like todd bowles
to basically you know you've got the
psyche mike you know you've just had
tyreek hill
catch balls for 269 yards he has
just totally run roughshod over your
defense
and so you know and you've got a defense
a secondary you know all six
guys who play a lot are 24 and younger
so
todd bowles came in the next day and he
just
you know very very uh you know flatline
said to him listen said that game
is one out of 16. we're gonna watch the
tape
we're gonna go over it and then at the
end we're gonna move on to the next one
he said just don't make a big deal of it
because it's not a big deal
we had two horrible plays in coverage
we got to get them fixed we will get
them fixed i'm not concerned don't be
concerned
and so when your coach is basically
not coming in ranting raving
uh you know throwing stuff against the
wall
and he just comes in he says hey it's
not good enough but we are better than
that i know we are
and we'll fix it that is how todd bowles
treated that game
i don't know how they'll react mike
because it's easy it's the classic old
mike tyson
hey you can talk a good game until you
get punched in the mouth
and and and that is the way
we're going to be looking at the buck
on super sunday have they learned their
lessons and have they adjusted
from when they first played this team
that
is going to tell the tale of this game
and the final score that game was 27-24
the buccaneers did wake up they were
notorious for much of the regular season
for spotting teams big leads sometimes
coming back
sometimes not coming back but you know
one thing we've seen from tampa bay the
past two weeks the postseason
they they beat a saints team that had
swept tampa bay including a 38-3
shellacking in prime time in week 9 on
sunday night football
and then when they faced the packers a
team they had blown out 38 to 10. that
was a much different game although at
one point it was 28 to 10 but
these games are snowflakes they're all
different and when you start it over
again
and you change the circumstances and you
make it single elimination
and in this case you make it for a super
bowl trophy
that that changes everything and you're
going to have
a lot of risk it and biscuit at least
attempting
by bruce arians and company i really do
think as we get closer and closer
to the game and we reflect on the things
the buccaneers have done
they're going to have not not tricks up
their sleeve per se
they're just going to have that attitude
of
we're going to go for it fourth down
we're going to go for it field goal
the hell with it touchdown you know
they're gonna have that mentality
because they've gotten to this point
with that that edge and that willingness
to take risks as as uh bruce erin said
the clip we played at the top of the
segment you got to be willing to swing
for the fences if you're going to hit a
home run
mike you know what it what occurs to me
as you watch tampa
as the season goes on i think we talked
about it a couple of weeks ago
you know when i was talking about in
that super bowl against atlanta
you know at the end of the game it's
chris hogan and malcolm mitchell
who tom brady is going to and i'm
thinking to myself how in the world
are you on the same page with these guys
in their first year and all that
and brady says 122 practices
and to not uh you know because i i we've
we've talked about this before but in my
opinion
tom brady if he's got talent okay
that's why you see that beautiful
rainbow arcing throw to scottie miller
right in his hands in the end zone over
kevin king
that's why you see the beautiful high
arcing
throw to mike evans uh early in the game
for the touchdown
in the end zone um you know that's right
over the packer corners
uh outstretched arms it's because
tom brady has to practice
he has to get in his reps he simply
must and when he does you get to the end
of the season
you see things like what he did in the
kansas city championship game
uh two three years ago when he kept
finding gronk down the seam in beautiful
throws
why he's practiced with gronk a thousand
times
they've done that a thousand times so i
think this
is really the time late in the year why
i
think brady's going to be dangerous in
this game and hey mahomes is always
dangerous
yeah i mean we are at the point where
tom brady is essentially into his second
season
with the tampa bay buccaneers you know
we talk about rookies by the time a
rookie gets to the playoffs they're not
rookies anymore we talked about tyler
johnson
how brady trusts him how brady trusts
scotty miller
you think about these weapons i mean
what a difference you know
fortunately this week hasn't been as
consumed with the whole
patriots comparison talk because brady
has punched through to the super bowl
but
i don't know that the patriots make the
playoffs even if brady stays because you
look at this murderer's row of pass
catchers that he has available to him
he's never had anything like that
at any point in his career and now he's
got that whether it's 122 practices or
whatever the number is because of the
pandemic
he's got that full experience with all
of them
they know him he knows them they know
the offense inside and out he's got a
couple of great running backs in leonard
for net and ronald jones
and uh yeah i tom brady couldn't have
landed in a better spot to get him
where he is short of maybe going to the
chiefs if for some reason they wouldn't
have had access to patrick mahomes this
year
you know mike one other thing you know i
kept thinking
and i kind of felt bad for cam newton
this year because
look he he looked like he was physically
diminished
but you didn't really know because of
the
the people he had around him and i bet
cam newton the entire year
said all the right things and said i got
to be better and
you know good for him that's what a
competitor should say
but anyway excuse me cam newton when i
am watching him play
i'm thinking he's got to go home and
drive away from the stadium tonight
thinking man
i know exactly what tom brady felt like
last year
at the end of the year he simply didn't
have
nfl caliber playoff weapons
period end of story all this stuff about
is it brady is it belichick
i i you know i just don't know who you
put
at quarterback you know from like
december of last year till january one
of this year
with the patriots who's really gonna
play well the reason that they're under
500
you know over their last whatever 18 20
games
is because they have not stocked
the pantry with contributing good
skill players on that team well and
they've got plenty of work to do
to get back to where they've been uh
because they they need the quarterback
they need
they need the skill players they need a
lot of things in new england and they
get to watch what happens when tom brady
lands in a spot where they have
everything that brady needed including a
surprisingly potent defense which has
been the difference
you know when brady had his meltdown on
sunday with the three interceptions
the defense stiffened and forced a pair
of three and outs
when the door was wide open for the
packers to take over that game and
possibly win it going away
i mean think about that peter three
three
straight drives with interceptions
from tom brady if the packers had won
that game can you imagine
what the story lines coming out of that
would have been it's almost like it
never happened because the buccaneers
won the game
the defense is the key devin white is
one of the keys
you know antoine winfield jr if he can
play jpp
shaq barrett and dominic and sue levante
david let's not forget him sean murphy
bunting who's had an interception
every game but i don't think brady
expected to land on a team with a
defense
that is almost as good as the defenses
he enjoyed when he was with new england
here's the amazing thing about this game
against the packers in my opinion mike
so you know we can look at the last
three offensive plays for green bay that
go incomplete incomplete
incomplete but on third nate you know
obviously aaron rodgers very badly wants
to get the ball to devonte adams
and to me he made a foolish throw
because really he didn't have anybody
open
in that secondary that's how well tampa
was playing but
but the point i'm gonna make is and the
reason why jason light
really needs to get a lot of credit for
this team
and his personnel staff it's not just
him but
why they deserve a lot of credit look at
the replay
on the last play of the game for for
green bay the last offensive play
rogers goes out of the pocket out of the
pocket he's looking looking looking and
finally
almost out of desperation he throws
almost a ground ball
to uh to devonta adams at the goal line
he was bracketed by two backup
safeties edwards and adams who
in the regular season you know it
basically played a total
of less than 200 snaps and so
to me that says that
one to 53 the tampa bay buccaneers have
built the kind of team
that should be able to be good for quite
a while brady not brady or not but
it's also the team that brady's going to
want to stay with for a while i would
think
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit
subscribe for the latest news and
highlights from nbc sports